okay now for our daily cancellation
speaking of aggressive we are going to
cancel aggressively and with great wrath
and vengeance everyone who is pushing
the police are kidnapping people
narrative
now we know this started in portland
when uniformed police officers were seen
arresting someone and putting them in an
unmarked vehicle
this is something that has happened
countless times over many decades it is
very normal
there is nothing unique or new about it
but suddenly somehow for some reason
it's a scandal
you know it's a it's a it's a horrible
thing that's happening where
we're you know arresting people in
unmarked vehicles so here's the latest
now a video
of someone being arrested by nypd has
gone viral and has the left to include
people like chris
hayes and jerry nadler very very upset
about this video just uh we'll play it
right now watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
there is nothing strange or upsetting or
disturbing about what you just saw
it's an arrest that's all yes the person
being arrested doesn't want to be
but that's pretty typical of arrests the
only other option aside from arresting
people like that is is to do it
consensually and
this appears to be what the left has in
mind you know this is the way they think
arrests should go now the officer should
walk up i guess
very very politely and say excuse me uh
but i noticed you committing a series of
felonies would you mind if i arrested
you for that
i mean you see we have these things
called laws and typically we wh what was
that oh you don't you don't want to be
arrested you know
oh well okay i had no idea so sorry to
bother you please please continue
here is this you're about to throw a
rock at a cop car right well here you go
here's the rock right back well
um please please proceed sorry to
interrupt
have a great day sir now i wish i was
joking that that is really what they
want
um many leftists in response to this
video
have declared that the arrest was
unjustified
how could they possibly know that from
that footage it seems like they just
have a problem with arrests
in general how can you see a video of
someone being arrested
no context no footage of what transpired
before it
and just know automatically that the
person is innocent
you don't even know what they're accused
of doing i don't know what this person
is accused of doing or
why they're being arrested but they're
innocent take me seriously
it doesn't make any sense um
if you know minor details like facts
matter
i'll tell you what they're arrested for
the nypd has
explained it here's nypd news on twitter
explaining they've got they put out a
series of tweets
it says in regard to a video on social
media that took place at uh second
avenue and
25th street a woman taken into custody
in an unmarked van
was wanted for damaging police cameras
during five separate criminal incidents
in and around city hall
the arresting officers were assaulted
with rocks and bottles
when officers from warrant squad took
the woman into custody in a gray nypd
minivan
this evening they were assaulted with
rocks and bottles the warren squad used
unmarked
vehicles to effectively locate wanted
suspects
uh which which makes a lot of sense it
makes sense to use them for that reason
they continue when she was placing the
warren squad's unmarked gray
minivan it was behind a cordon cordon of
uh nypd bicycle cops in bright yellow
and blue uniform shirts
there to help affect the arrest um
makes sense to me nonetheless people
like
chris hayes as you can see here say this
is kidnapping
this is dot dot dot kidnapping
very very dramatic no chris
this is not kidnapping this is making an
arrest
that's what it looks like sorry to
scandalize you you hysterical child
oh they're using unmarked vans the vans
are unmarked
so why does that matter i say again
there is nothing strange new or scary
about unmarked cop cars
police have been using unmarked cop cars
for decades they use them as was just
explained because sometimes the cops
don't want criminals to know they're
coming this is not a scandal
this isn't anything it's just normal
stuff
very normal stuff um
now we have here's what jerry nadler a
giant potato come to life that's my
theory anyway on jerry nadler
here's what he has to say about this he
sent out a tweet
this video of a protester in new york
city being thrown in unmarked van is
terrifying and should be unacceptable to
everyone who respects the constitutional
rights
this country was founded on um
there must be an immediate explanation
for this anonymous use of force
anonymous anonymous
they have bright neon uniforms that say
police on them
you potato this is what we get for
electing potatoes to
public office i've always said we
shouldn't you know we should stick with
with you know non-potatoes at least
nadler says he's terrified
terrified of the concept of police
making lawful arrests and putting
suspects into unmarked vehicles
which they've done millions of times
since the investment of the automobile
did nadler just start being terrified by
this now or has he always been terrified
of unmarked police cars
why didn't he say anything earlier he
could have got some medication or
something
he's driving down the road he's an
unmarked cop car at a you know
doing traffic stops does he break down
in tears
petrified so just to review here it is
not illegal for cops to use unmarked
vehicles
they do it all the time it makes sense
to use them because oftentimes criminals
don't want to be arrested and will run
away if you announce your arrival
and in fact despite claims to the
contrary it actually
doesn't matter if criminals don't want
to be arrested
they can still be arrested even if they
don't want to be
and it's not kidnapping because police
have a resting powers
and that's why everyone complaining
about this is canceled
and they're all potatoes all of them
potatoes are canceled too
just for the record just to cover all
the bases
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated